[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
to the bishop and first lady new
psalmist family
- the Cummings family Maya mr. president
madam secretary madam Speaker governor
friends colleagues staff the seeds on
good soil the parable of the sower tells
us stands for those with a noble and
good heart who hear the word retain it
and by persevering produce a crop the
seed on good soil Elijah Cummings came
from good sort
and in this sturdy frame goodness took
root
his parents were sharecroppers from the
south
they picked tobacco and strawberries and
then sought something better in this
city South Baltimore and Robert worked
shifts at a plant and Ruth cleaned other
people's homes they became parents of
seven preachers to a small flock I
remember I had the pleasure of meeting
Eliza's mother Ruth and she told me she
prayed for me every day and I knew it
was true and I felt better for it
sometimes people say they're praying for
you and you don't know
they might be praying about you but you
don't know if they're praying for you
but I knew miss Ruth was telling the
truth so they were the proverbial salt
of the earth and they passed on that
strength and that grit but also that
kindness and that faith to their son as
a boy
Elijah's dad made him shine his shoes
and tie his tie and they'd go to the
airport not to bore their planes but to
watch others do it I remember Elijah
telling me this story Robert would say I
have not flied I may not fly but you
will fly one day we can't afford it
right now but you will fly as
grandmother as Elijah related and as
grandmother's do was a little more
impatient with her advice your daddy
she said he'd been waiting and waiting
and waiting for a better day don't you
wait and Elijah did not wait against all
odds
Elijah earned his degrees he learned
about the rights that all people in this
country are supposed to possess with
little help apparently from Perry Mason
Alijah became a lawyer to make sure that
others had rights and his people had
their god-given rights and from the
Statehouse to the House of
Representatives his commitment to
justice and the rights of others would
never ever waver
Elijah's example the son of parents who
rose from nothing to carve out just a
little something the public servant who
toiled to guarantee the least of us have
the same opportunities that he had
earned a leader who once said he died
for his people even as he lived every
minute for them his life validates the
things we tell ourselves about what's
possible in this country not guaranteed
but possible
the possibility that our destinies are
not preordained but rather through our
works and our dedication and our
willingness to open our hearts to God's
message of love for all people we can
live a purposeful life that we can reap
a bountiful harvest but we are neither
sentenced to wither among the rocks nor
assured of bounty but we have the
capacity the chance as individuals and
as a nation to root ourselves in good
soil
Elijah understood that that's why I
fought for justice that's why he
embraced this beloved community of
Baltimore that's why he went on to fight
for the rights and opportunities of
Forgotten people all across America not
just in his district
[Applause]
he was never complacent free knew that
without clarity of purpose and a
steadfast faith and the dogged
determination demanded by our Liberty
the promise of this nation can wither
complacency he knew was not only
corrosive for our collective lives but
for our individual lives it's been
remarked that Elijah was a kind man
I tell my daughters and I have to say
listening to Elijah's daughter's speak
that got me choked up I'm sure those of
you have sons feel the same way but
there's something about daughters and
their father
[Applause]
and I was thinking I'd want my daughters
to know how much I love them but I'd
also want them to know that being a
strong man includes being kind that
there's nothing weak about kindness and
compassion
there's nothing weak about looking out
for us there's nothing there's nothing
weak about being honorable you're not a
sucker to have integrity and to treat
others with respect
I was sitting here and I was just
noticing the Honorable Elijah Eve comes
and you know this is a title that we
confer on all kinds of people who get
elected to public office
[Applause]
we're supposed to introduce them as
honorable but but Elijah Cummings was
honorable before he was elected office
there's a difference
there's a difference
if you were honorable and treated others
honorably outside the limelight on the
side of a road in a quiet moment
counseling and somebody who work with
letting your daughters know you love
them you know as president I knew I
could always count on Elijah being
honorable and doing the right thing and
people have talked about his voice there
is something about his voice it just
made you feel better you know there are
some people that you have that deep
baritone a prophetic voice and when it
was good times and we achieved victories
together that boys and then laugh was a
gift but you needed it more during the
tough times when the path ahead look
crooked when obstacles abounded when I
entertained doubts or I saw those who
were in the fight start to waver
that's what Elijah's voice mattered most
and more than once during my presidency
when the economy still looked like it
might plunge into depression when the
health care bill was pronounced dead in
Congress I would watch Elijah rally his
colleagues the cost of doing nothing
isn't nothing he would say and folks
would remember why they entered into
public service our children are the
living messengers we send to a future we
will never see
he would say and he would remind all of
us that our time is too short not to
fight for what's good and what is true
and what is best in America
two hundred years two three hundred
years from now he would say people will
look back at this moment and they will
ask the question what did you do and
hearing him we would be reminded that it
falls upon each of us to give voice to
the voices and comfort to the sick an
opportunity to those not born to it and
to preserve and nurture our democracy
Elijah Cummings was a man of noble and
good heart his parents and his faith
planted the seeds of hope and love and
compassion and righteousness in that
good soil of his he has harvested all
the crop that he could for the Lord has
now called Elijah home to give his
humble faithful servant recipe and it
now falls on us to continue his work so
that other young boys and girls in
Baltimore across Maryland across the
United States and around the world might
to have a chance to grow and to flourish
that's how we will honor him